you are the sister who is behind the
post
on social media which went quite viral
up you know
there was two messages that you sent
when you sent those i knew
at that moment of time i think you was
with them um should i read it i don't
know
i can cut this be out if you want here
but this is what you sent me yeah i i
don't wanna i don't wanna make you like
a thing it was nothing there was nothing
deeper he was like ali drama always got
some drama going on
uh and when he wrote when he wrote ali
drama sister
that's that's that's something that a
nickname they've given to me like ali
needs tawa
and ali drama so i was scrolling up and
i was saying why did i
block the sister but do you see
subhanallah look where you're now sister
and back then and we all make mistakes
like don't get twisted about well
no no sister so when i first became
muslim he my dad was actually okay
so my dad was actually like you know
what um if that's what you want to do
it's up to you if you want to live like
a pakistani religion it's up to you my
dad has had this view
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters in
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome
back um i'm not intending on doing these
uh
long discussions but topics uh come up
and we do it
so last week we had sister fahima we
talked about
uh the sisters hijab it's going back
back back and back that was all
discussion it was quite good inshallah
and it's good to have a sister's
perspective on as well but today we're
not talking about that
uh how you doing sister mira good job
how are you yeah i bless you inshallah
uh i'm at zeeshan's house i don't know
if you've seen these videos before
you don't smile yeah yeah yeah he's just
he's just making me laugh a bit so i'm
sorry if i'm
giggling it's just it's he's making
himself i thought he died
firstly may allah bless you inshallah
for um taking the time out
um the reason i wanted to do this is
because
personally i kind of related to your
story and you are the sister who is
behind
the post on social media which went
quite viral
and if i'm not mistaken i just saw in
your story that in russia it's been
shared
yeah it's gone viral on russia i don't
know how that happened but someone
who's got a big russian channel they
basically translate it into russian
and it's gone crazy i actually woke up
this morning with like hundreds of
followers from russia and i thought
that's strange you know
and i got watching dms and i was like
that's really weird cause i didn't know
the language i put it into google
translate as russian
and then i realized literally this
afternoon when it went viral in russia
so
i don't like i have no idea how it got
there but
it did so that's that's amazing you know
allah works in uh miraculous ways
um sister tell us a bit about yourself
you know let's let's start from the
beginning
you are a you're a married sister with
three kids um
may allah preserve your uh marriage
uh give you more righteous children
inshallah and i've seen on your story my
sort of beautiful
kids memorizing the quran reciting quran
as they walk in
really heartwarming mashallah and may
allah preserve your family can you tell
me
let's start from the beginning in the
context of
how long have you been a muslim by the
way um so i became awesome
in august 2012. okay uh
and my brother's muslim as well so he
actually became muslim first
okay um his wife is a reaver as well so
there's quite a lot of us in our family
which is
quite strange you don't usually sort of
find the whole sort of family of
rebirths but um
yeah 2012 he's the one that sort of
introduced me to islam and
you know with the very close yesterday
and everything handed out
the bond has got stronger due to islam
as well so
so we're looking at nine going ten years
yeah yeah okay that's that's amazing to
be honest a lot of when anyone comes to
islam i tell them like
if you think about they're like the
ambassadors of islam i believe genuinely
allah picks them
for them to spread the islam into their
family you know that's why you see a lot
of reverb people coming to islam they're
like oh my mom accepted his daughter my
daddy said
my brother so it's like they're the
ambassador and it starts off with them
um and even though the reason i mention
this is because a lot of them are afraid
like oh if my mom finds out
what my dad finds out that yes those
struggles are there which we're going to
talk about and this is what exactly this
topic is about
but i tell them not do not despair
because you might be the reason that the
very family member that hates islam
might come to islam
so tell us what made you come to islam
firstly
um so again my brother became muslim
first and he just used to basically talk
to you about islam obviously when you
know you're
new to islam you're very passionate and
you want the whole world to be muslim
you just want to share this amazing news
so he was very much like that
and his wife moved in our home i was
living with my mother at the time
and so she became a very close friend to
me and um even i didn't
with you know the religious views they
had i really respected her and liked her
as a person
and they were just very sweet and they
were just very kind in the way they said
you know
talk to me about islam and they always
tell me like the positive things
um and then yeah my brother would always
try and give me some books and stuff and
i'd say you know i'm not really a reader
so then what he would do is on a friday
night he would order a takeaway and say
why didn't you come and sit in our room
with us and just watch something so i'd
be like yeah
sure you know and he ended up putting on
a um islamic lecture
um i thought he was going to put on a
movie but he's not an islamic lecturer
i think it was um maybe it was ahmeda or
something like that i think it was
something like that
and yeah and i was just sat there
watching it just to be respectful for
like five ten minutes and i thought you
know that's quite good it's quite nice
i didn't know very very nice nothing
really wrong with it
and then the following week i ended up
doing the same thing so it became like a
tradition almost that every friday if i
didn't go out with my friend
i would sit in the room with them and
have a takeaway and we'd watch these
islamic lectures so
i um did start to become interested that
way
and um my group of friends remember that
they were you know found it a bit
strange i didn't really discuss it with
them um and we had a holiday
we were going to iron upper which is a
like a party resort you know
in cyprus and we were going there and i
actually felt like i didn't know because
i had this feeling in me like oh it's
wrong you know shouldn't you do it you
know even i wasn't muslim
and when i actually got there my brother
had put a quran into my bag
so when i got there when i opened my
suitcase i opened my suitcase and saw
koranas powerline it literally
it really hit me about that you know
this is
i this is i want to change my life i
want to be muslim and it was only
actually standing on the balcony there i
remember
very clearly that i was standing on the
balcony in the hotel room and there was
lots of people you know drinking and
smoking and i remember seeing one woman
being sick everywhere there was a guy
collapsed everywhere there was a hot dog
stand there was always you know you can
imagine going on in a
party place you know so i'm looking down
from this about
all of a sudden
i just saw everything before i was being
sick someone just passing out someone
just you know i thought
this can't be the way that we're
supposed to live and end i just thought
for one moment
islam must be true we must have you know
the creator who made everything has
given us an instruction to live by and
it's and this is not here
so yeah allah lifted the veil of my eyes
at that very moment and that's when i
found my brother and said do i want to
take shahada i want to be muslim you
know what do i say what do i do
and i was in a different country and i
said i don't know i just want to be
muslim like right now what do i say what
do i do you know
so you're in cyprus you went there for
you know party holiday he puts a quran
actually he's muslim must be a very
beautiful brother too you know
he's very dedicated for you know doing a
little uh slight way of giving dawah so
you wanted to accept islam in cyprus
yeah like i said to him on the phone
like i want to do it now and he was like
you know calm down like you're okay i
was like no no no but what if i die like
what what
and i was like these things were going
for my mind like you know what if i die
here i don't want to die here i don't
wanna
start just panicking you know thinking i
just want to be like i just want to be a
believer you know
that's what do i do and then he said to
me say the shahada and i said the
shahada but i just wanted to come back
and do it in a masjid
anyway so i came back to england yeah
and the next day i went to a masjid
and said much i heard a message as well
and i got like a reverse certificate
thing
and everything like that and then that's
just sort of how the
journey's been marshall that's amazing
okay so that's uh
yeah um yeah so okay
so can you tell me you know when your
brother accepted islam because we know
the whole story that's going viral on
social media is that your dad didn't
speak to you for five years
did he know about your your brother
except in islam as well
yeah so when he when we were we're very
close to my father
when we when my brother became muslim my
my dad just thought it was just a thing
he was going through
it wasn't really such a big change like
my brother married a white reverse
sister
you know okay so yeah so she's a reader
as well so
my brother and her boyfriend my dad just
thought you know he's just
he just loves this girl and he's just
done it for this girl and they're all
right they're not really finding anyone
they're just you know they're not really
they're not really doing anything
different you know what you mean um
it was only when i became muslim that at
first he was a bit
he wasn't that happy okay so
when he was your brother he was okay
with it but when it was you
that's where he was like okay uh now
maybe the thing is
in his mind he's thinking okay as a man
he's done it for
this girl that he wants to marry but as
a woman he pro maybe he believed that
you're being oppressed
you know um so that's why in his head
maybe he didn't like it
now how how did he find out that you
accepted islam
and how did your relationship
deteriorate from there
so when i first became muslim my dad was
actually okay
so my dad was actually like you know
what um if that's what you want to do
it's up to you if you want to live like
a pakistani religion it's up to you my
dad has had this view of like a
religion yeah he was like if you
wouldn't live with pakistani religion
do you know so he was actually he was
all right at first
and i remember he just didn't like the
fact that i wouldn't go to the pub with
him
anymore i would um go to his barbecues
with his friends anymore it was these
things that he
started to find a bit he didn't really
like um
but at this point there was no problem
there wasn't any dramatics he wasn't
being horrible to me there wasn't
anything like that
um he was completely fine we were very
on good terms for at least three years
um even went outside with me with
nicaragua on you know in the fab and
everything he was fine for a good four
years
it was only when he he left my mum
separated from my mum
and he met a new woman who was part of
the edl
and this is how this be that he began
his journey with the edl
okay okay so um
how was his treatment deteriorating in
the context where
first he was accepted then he got
divorced and remarried and this person
he remarried was
involved with the edl how was his
treatment towards you
um well it started off with him just
sending me messages in the night time
like strange messages like um what's
going on in syria
or um what what's um what what are
muslims up to in afghanistan and things
like that like muslims you start saying
things like muzzies and
um stuff like that and i'd say you know
i don't know what happens in afghanistan
i don't have no idea i don't know what's
going on syria and he's like course you
do
no like lol things like that and i'd be
like why is my dad sending me
things like that for like you know he i
didn't think he was ignorant like my
dad's always
loved being english he's proud of
england he's very patriotic but
and he doesn't like foreigners he never
likes foreigners but he would never
verbally he would never vocalize it that
sort of thing you know
and he would always say i'm not racist
i've got black friends i've got asian
friends so he was very much like that
person but for him to start vocalizing
these things it was very strange
and then obviously i tried to say to my
dad like you know i don't know what's
going on these countries and he'd say
yeah you do you all do
you're all in on it things like that and
i'll say like what do you mean
and then he's like saying you know um if
someone should punch you in the face if
they see a bin bag on your face like
that
you know things like that and i was it
was just it definitely my own father was
saying things like that
and i would be like you know try and
call him and message him like dad like
why are you saying these things like
that's just
why i don't know and um yeah and
basically i found out that he was going
to a specific pub
where they they all go together and
um basically they'd found out my dad has
muslim children
so it become like my dad had to now show
that he's basically not with us
he's not with me and my brother doesn't
stand with me my brother he's completely
against my veil
against everything you know so what
would you say like would you say
obviously we know that your story is
that after five years he boycotted you
he came back he accepted you you guys
went
and went to get something to eat uh got
dessert
um that's an amazing feeling do you
think anything that you may have done
that may have
in his mind be like you know what this
is my daughter of course he would think
that but you know
would you say you gave him um not just
verbally
let's talk about something which is
important because we do know
that just after we discuss this point
we're going to be discussing the traps
reverse fall into and you was a part of
a specific group you don't want me to
mention and i'm not going to mention
because i said a manner
um and you was heavily influenced with
them so much so that
i actually blocked you i don't know like
i i actually remember that i blocked you
uh we had a and this is kind of how
allah changes things around
um and and i was i was looking for you
when this your story went right
i was looking for you and i was like why
can't i find an account why can't i find
an account
and i realized that i had blocked you
and then i unblocked you
and then you mentioned to me and we're
gonna come to that later
but um what would you say for example
um do you think like your man is
was you harsh with your dad in the
context like you know some people go
through this phase where they're like
yeah you know there's cofad and this
kind of attitude or was you gentle
what made you think you played a role in
your dad coming after five years
or do you think it was just his own
experience where he joined the edl and
he thought you know what this is
actually nonsense and he may have
come across some dao videos whoever it
may be whoever from whoever
and that might have changed his mind
what do you what do you think played a
role in your dad doing a u-turn
so um i don't want to take all the
credit for it because obviously like his
experience with the edl i think it's
what solidified his turning away from
them
which i can talk about later but um i
would say that with my father like i
used to always buy him things that he
really liked so he when he started to
turn a bit strange with me i'd always
buy him oranges
he loves oranges and that's such a small
thing but my dad used to love these
oranges from this turkish shop
and my dad always like you can say you
know when you because i used to live
near this turkey shop and you say
whenever you go by there could you get
them for me
so i was always like buying him these
oranges and i text them even though my
dad was saying oh you know
are you ever gonna take that um that
black bin bag off your head i'd respond
and say dad
do you want any more oranges i'm just at
the like shop i'll get them for you like
how many do you want like i didn't
actually respond to his like sort of
insults i was just saying no yeah would
you like me to buy these for you
and i remember once my dad was like oh
i'm so tired like i had a really
late one last night i was drinking
whatever and he was like you know um
but um are you when you have your baby
is your baby gonna be a
a muslim as well right would you already
know or my kids were muslim but he was
like are they gonna be a muslim as well
and i said oh yeah would you like me to
come and clean your flat for you
so like i would respond to him as nice
as i could and i always offered to do
things for him that i know he needed
help with
yeah um so yeah i would say like i did
try and keep that
that going even when he i didn't speak
to him for five years i'd always send
him an email
but hi dad how are you especially during
lockdown when the when the pandemic came
on lockdown
i said to my dad i'm worried about you
there's a lockdown where are you are you
in this country are you not like i'm
worried about you
um can you call me like i was worried
that my dad might have covered you know
you know you don't know
um so i said dad look if you have like
if you have any symptoms like make sure
you go to doctor like please like
message me call me i was like frantic
sending a lot of messages and i didn't
get any
response and it literally was just two
months ago his response to me
and it was just like i'm okay now you
know i'm fine i'm not i've not
got covered and i was all right and he
was just basically like i'm sorry for
everything i've said anything i've done
and
i made a big mistake with my life and
i've wasted basically five years of my
life
for nothing so i would say it was
a part of me being gentle to him and
being understanding and also just loving
my father i love him
that's amazing you know if we think
about it you know the prophet salallahu
sallam
if we look at him you know there was
sahabah who accepted islam
without seeing miracles in that context
because they knew him to be the truthful
i was reading the book um
the eternal challenge actually mohammed
recommended it it's a brilliant book and
if you think about it
i would recommend anyone to read it as
well and they
believed in his message because they
knew him it was his character
and this is so fundamental in the dawah
it was his character that they said
there's no way this person is lying
because we know him to be
truthful he's honest he doesn't lie he's
you know so much so his enemies the the
quraysh
would leave their belongings with him
and if you look at it his character
played such a massive role
that when he said that he's receiving
revelation
they couldn't doubt that they couldn't
say you know what is this man i know
it's not a liar he's truthful look at
his
character amazing character so the thing
is it's so fundamental and i believe
this is fundamental
because you i believe played the massive
role in him coming because in his head
he's gonna be thinking and this is where
i relate
with your story because i can remember
times when my dad would open tv and see
bin laden
and say look there's your friend it
literally says look these are your
friends
and he would you know say these remarks
all the time
and yes sometimes you ignore it but
sometimes it gets to you you know so i
understand where you're coming from and
i tried my best to fight that hate with
love
you know and i would sometimes go and
just like you know kiss him in the head
and say dad
you know like i'm still me in that
context and i believe and
i saw and i saw in him that this
disarmed him every time he was
aggressive towards me verbally there was
only one time he was
like physically once he was you know but
the thing is
verbally anytime he was like aggressive
towards me i realized that
the love and the kindness that i showed
him
disarmed him and i can remember a point
in in my life when my when he was saying
certain things to me and my mom came and
said
you know like what you want from him
like what does he do to you look look i
mean look how you insult him 24 7.
and i think that plays a massive role
and i believe that i did so when you
asked your dad
dad like what happened
you know after five years did he tell
you
yeah he did he just said basically that
he had
um a lot of problems with the specific
group he was with edl
and there was a lot of fights amongst
the people because they're drinkers you
know they go to the pub they have a
drink
you know things get wild and there's a
lot of um
yeah so they were getting into these
altercations
and you know fighting each other and my
dad said you know some of them were
making comments about your children and
muslim didn't let it go it was a big
thing you know
and actually one thing that stood out to
my dad was that basically they were
ready to basically
jump on anyone so they were like you
know if we see this person we see this
and
my dad is like not my dad's not for her
and women and children
yeah and that's what my dad thought this
is not right
because my dad would say you know what
we need to get my dad would say you know
what we need to get the terrorists we
need to get the bad people we need to
get the ones that are basically trying
to infiltrate this country right would
they agree with
but when it came to let's go and hurt
that woman with a bin bag on her head
my dad's like um is she really a
terrorist i think she's just
she's just a muslim woman she's not
really a terrorist so i think that's
what
kind of was a turning point and
obviously my dad must have remembered
you know my treatment towards him and
know that i was never bad to him and
it's someone like me that they would
actually start
on you know someone like me
sister amira i believe your dad is a
i believe inshallah would accept islam i
can see it because i don't believe
that he did not attack woman in hijab
because he thought okay
that's my daughter i don't think he
didn't do that because of that
i believe he genuinely didn't do it
because that's in that's that's who he
is
he wouldn't attack women he wouldn't
want to harm and from what you've told
me about him he's he's gone through that
and like we look we know
um like he was on his way to kill the
prophet peace be upon him you know
um and i know that some people say it's
weird story but but the thing is
he was on his way and he he had a u-turn
and the process teller made dua for him
that may one of the two
um be guided and um with his
hate and vengeance but deep inside when
you have an atom way of
justice um in in your heart and you know
like you know this is the truth
he changed and i believe like personally
inshallah who makes
allah cause allah is the one charge in
the hearts of the hearts
i believe your dad will come to islam
inshallah and and me myself hijab
we are at your service if your dad would
like to speak sit down go out any and
i'm sure your brother's there you don't
need us i'm just saying you know we're
just here if if anything's needed your
brother marshall is amazing though i'm
sure your husband can do
uh amazing dao as well but if there's
anything you need right your services
stop
now and that's a good way of you know
like dean what you mentioned about how
you treated them is a brilliant way for
reverse who
have come to islam the best way to deal
with your parents is
they they've brought you to this age
they're a baby they
they don't want to learn anything from
you but there's one thing that they can
learn
and have no choice but to learn is to
observe you because that's not something
you can it's not like
i don't want to watch them yeah you can
say i don't want to hear
don't talk to me no don't educate me you
don't know me better than better than me
but there's one thing that they can't
stop they can stop you from talking
but they cannot stop you from being the
true muslim you are
and observing your adam and character
because that's something they have to
observe and they look at you
and once that once they see how islam
has made you
amazing character and they've seen the
because aishwarya has said the prophet
peace be upon him was the walking
talking quran
they saw tawheed in him
because we have a lot of people and i'm
going to slowly go to this
issue of this cult that you joined and
um if you think about it you know
there's this emphasis on you know tohi
tohit you know uh
this person is misguided or this person
is a catholic or whatever it may be
it's that people think that
dawa is something that is verbalized in
the context of
there's certain phraseologies or phrases
that you have to
repeat over and over again and i believe
the best form of dawah like the prophet
peace be for him said he said i came for
nothing
but to perfect good adap you know and
the salaf would say the self would say i
would rather my
son read a chapter on good than 70
chapters on knowledge
uh we know imam ahmed when he used to
give a talk some say you know it might
be exaggerated 30
000 people would come to listen and one
fourth or no three um
about 75 percent of people who came they
came to observe as good ah
good manners and if you read
you will see it now i just want to
mention this because this is really
important because you're a weaver yeah
and i kind of had a rubbed shoulders
with this
uh these kind of group of people
what advice would you give and can you
just briefly tell me if you're okay with
it because i know you said you're not
comfortable
and the reason you're not comfortable is
not that you want you don't want to warn
other sisters or brothers
but it's because you you feared that
they might bully you or whatever
we know how toxic they can be
how did you fall into this how do you
think it changed you as a person
looking back now what would you advise a
reaver that's watching this you've come
to islam new
and they are actually being invited by
this cult like
tell me a bit about how you joined them
so i would say that like when you become
muslim there's lots of different people
trying to grab your attention at that
time
um there's well-known groups there's
groups that are not really well known
and some of them are pondered true some
of them are not some of them
you know some of them are just normal
people they just want to get you they
just want to read that's gonna get you
in and a lot of them probably mean well
but a lot of them sadly don't um so i'd
say yeah when i first became muslim
um some of the types of people that i
met at the time like you know you need
to come to this
you need to come to this mosque you need
to come to this mosque and this is the
mosque of the truth so you're like okay
it's true you know i have to do it.
so you go to this mosque and you get
there and everything's very there's
there's rules for everything
everything's a rule and a regulation you
know what a lot of people when they
first become muslim
some of them reverts have actually been
at the lowest part of their life to
actually accept islam
so some people come into islam with
mental health issues some people come to
islam at a really low point they
they're not ready to be forced into
whole life and rules and stuff they
know that god is one and that he has
messengers you know and they've accepted
the truth of
the oneness one line is and all these
messengers just just to touch upon
saying what you said
if the quran was to come down with halal
and haram nobody will come
become a muslim this is so important
because we do things the opposite way
that's haram
first you put you give increase the iman
once iman enters the heart that person
would leave the haram himself
and but these people they're a whole
different level but carry on sister yeah
i just wanted to add that there
yeah some people come to islam and
they're still in a relationship some
people come to islam they still got
addiction so it's this
very um like this way okay now you're
now you're muslim there's all these
rules and regulations have to follow and
if you're not you're going to be kicked
out and basically we're going to let you
know that you're clicked out and you're
not going to come back here and we're
basically going to make your life hell
so
that's the sort of um thing i
experienced personally
and it's like it's it's not um it's not
fruitful from my experience and all the
sisters that i've come into contact with
over the eight nine years is not
fruitful at all and you find that a lot
of people who join this very very strict
way
they actually can't live their own rigid
um
the way they're trying to teach other
people to live so rigid they can't live
it then
live it themselves and the prophet peace
be upon him said if you over burden
yourself
you oh basically if you go to extremes
it will overtake you basically it would
yeah it's like carrying a big mountain
on the shore it's gonna
destroy it's gonna you know yeah the
thing is here this is what happens and
like you said
they come to a point what they preach
they they can't do anything because it's
in near impossible
and that's what allah says
something that you yourself don't do um
yeah would you say that because i
believe
like they're the cancer of this ummah
genuinely i believe they have a cancer
because
and anyone that comes to islam i don't
know if you've seen anyone that comes to
islam i specifically tell them
be careful because you know what's sad
to me
is that somebody who's coming to islam
and seeing the beauty of islam
joining this cult or joining this group
and be like and some
they leave islam some of them follow the
deen most involved the deen
and some of them they totally leave
islam and they are left with this
perception of islam
did you feel like you was when you
joined them
did your character change would you say
you saw changes in yourself or your
surroundings
um see the thing is with me i've always
been quite like a strong person so when
i was
when i was in their company and i was
sort of going to these messages and i
was hearing these things on the speaker
and the hotbar on the fridays and stuff
i was sitting next to me
i was literally the sister next to me i
was saying to her do you believe in this
does this sound right to you yeah is
this we're not allowed to sorry we're
not allowed to go to another mission
why are these people bad luck and i was
basically because they were talking
about em she and it was the imam's wife
and she and she was sat next to me
remember she said yes this is the huck
this is the truth and i was like oh okay
and i just i went home that day and i
was like no if it seems right why are
you so angry why is it so angry why are
you screaming on the microphone about
other people i don't know
yeah so they were screaming like on the
microphone and i was like
this i was like this is and so basically
i then went to do my research and i
started doing my reading my own thing
and doing my own thing
and then i moved to east london i was
like you know what it's a muslim area
i'm going to move to east london so i
learned a complete different view of
islam living in east london
going to white chapel masjid and so when
i returned back to where i'm from
uh reading when i was turned back um
basically
they were like you know you're you're
now upon misguidance you're up on vidi
you've learned this and i was like well
actually no i've gone to study at table
and i've learned
i've learned how to read the quran so i
think i'm all right wow
wow wow say that again say that again
repeat that again
no i went and studied at um in east
london and i i learned ted speed and i
learned to read the quran
yeah so that i think i'm doing quite
well actually
look at this is that they're saying to
you are you up on innovation you went
and used that
time that you would have been busy
calling your innovator innovator i'm
updating
too concerned about other people and
darkening your heart you connected to
the quran
you learned to dread and that well if
that's misguidance i would love to be on
this guidance i'll be the biggest
call me the alibi well if that's
misguided that you're connecting
and i'm not saying they're directly
saying that but you spend your time so
wisely that you got connected to the
book of allah
and you freed yourself from them
subhanallah i don't want to make
um uh you know there was two messages
did you scroll
up you know there was two messages that
you sent when you sent those i knew
at that moment of time i think you was
with them um so i really i don't wanna i
can cut this be out if you want there
but this is what you sent me yeah i
i don't wanna i don't wanna make you
like a thing it was nothing it was
nothing deeper he was like
ali drama always got some drama going on
uh and when he wrote when he wrote ali
drama sister
that's that's that's something that a
nickname they've given to me like ali
needs tawa
and ali drama so i was scrolling up and
i was saying why did i
block the sister but do you see
subhanallah look where you're now sister
and back then we all make mistakes that
don't get twisted
believe me the moment when i heard you
that story and that
you left them to me it's like the moment
you leave them i know
your eyes have opened you know and and
we can communicate and talk may allah
bless you
um and subhanallah it's it's
what how would you what advice would you
give to a revert to
be careful to these groups what would
you say specifically sisters because
sisters sadly with these groups as well
they do get used and passed around i'm
not saying oh
i'm going to be just i'm not going to
say they all do that that's that's i
have to fearless
but they on they some of them
are known to marry sisters and divorce
them maori citizens divorce them
and wallah is as if they are carrying
jahiliyyah what they would do in
jahiliyyah
into islam in a halal way of marrying
divorcing they
it's as if they hunt for rivers it's as
if
it's it's as if they literally go and
hunt for those
who have that lifestyle because if you
think about it's a bit like a gang it's
like blood in blood out
and there's things that they do it's
like they've adopted adopted
this giant culture and brought it to
islam and made their little
thing and and there's many scholars i
mean many scholarship the grand mufti of
uh
um they've they've these people
referenced them
and these people warn against these
individuals
yeah and this behavior is sort of
unheard of when you go to the muslim
countries
um egypt or saudi arabia these this
these people unheard of and this
behavior is unheard of and this is not
something that
um that they do in muslim countries at
all it's completely just an isolated
group
basically it's not an isolated case but
it's not a group of people doing
these things so yeah i have definitely
experienced it and um handler
i didn't marry anyone that's like that
yeah i
i saw very quickly yeah
that's good you know what i want to do
let's get away from the negativity
and anyone all the sisters or brothers
who have come to islam be very careful
to be
called into groups and all this kind of
stuff be very careful inshallah
personally i recommend people to watch
people like
uh uh you know they're very
balanced and and let's make it very
clear the salafi community
we don't want to put all them in the
same bag they're not yeah we believe
the the methodology of our salafi
brothers is
on the hak and even though we may differ
certain things but the thing is that
to put all of them in the same basket i
want to make that very clear that
they're not the same you know
you know and many people subhan allah
that i recommend to follow
but let's move away from the inshallah
how's your dad like i'll be honest
yeah one thing that i would say about
the river that uh coming to islam and i
knew to islam
i would say that the best thing for them
to do is to independently study so go to
an institute
study in a reputable institute rather
than going to a specific group or trying
to find which group you should be in go
to an institute go to taiban
go to medina college go to institutes
places that you can actually learn
independently and study
alongside people that will actually age
you and support you
and they're all there sort of doing the
same thing and you're you're not there
to
it's not about anyone else's about
yourself so i would say that you know
becoming muslim is about
um self-refinement it's not about what
other people are doing because allah is
not going to ask you about what other
people are doing
it's actually about yourself and
refining yourself and making you
your whole focus in your life should be
yourself because it's the same as saying
i always say to myself
when you point the finger you've always
got four pointing back at you yeah
exactly
um okay yeah so um yeah so how was your
dad
like for example is he would you say
he's close to islam
is he closer to the grandkids has he met
your husband
yeah so um my dad hasn't actually met
the kids sadly he's met the baby
we haven't met the kids at our first
meeting it was quite
emotional and it was yeah so our first
meeting up because my dad hasn't met too
of
his grandchildren he hasn't met two of
my children exactly
um because i've had them in the time
that he was away you know which is quite
sad but um
yeah so he's met the youngest he met the
baby i took her with me to
to meet with him and so far he hasn't
seen anyone else yet so
inshallah in the future but he
definitely wants to do in the future
inshallah
that's amazing you know supanolo yeah i
don't know
any any last words that you would
give you know um you know it's an
amazing story i'll be honest with you
it's very heart touching
um and i know i don't know how it is how
it feels you know to have the fear of
you know
losing them as disbelievers you know um
and living with that fear
day in day out you know um i know how it
feels you know that's why i felt really
close to your story
um yeah what advice would you give maybe
i think we have already given
but maybe last words on me reverts and
how to deal with their family
what advice would you give them i'd
always say like with your family just
keep trying and like i said like in the
video like the video that went viral
like
it was quite cliche but it's true never
lose hope because if my dad
like anyone can like my dad was
literally in a group of people who are
against the muslims in this country
like they're just against everything
that we stand for and my dad completely
changed his part and it was actually at
that moment when he was alone like he
wasn't with that woman anymore he was
alone
and my dad no longer had these people
around that's when he sat and reflected
on his life
um so if like my dad can have this
reflection moment like anyone can
so i just say like always just be kind
to parents like there's this kid's
cartoon my my daughter's watching that
kitty and zackie and friends
yeah like be good guys and be kind to
your parents like and this literally i
always say the same thing like just be
kind to your parents is literally
it because there's nothing they could
they could never be horrible to you and
you're being so kind to them you know
my dad's like proof of it my dad's a
typical skin head tattoos everywhere
english guy you know
um and you know he he now is fine with
islam he's happy and he's just happy to
be
back in contact with me and he even gave
me some gifts i forgot to mention this
before
and when we left yeah when we left that
day he was really proud of himself he
was so he was so pleased like
he had a car that his um boot full of
all these boxes of toys and whatever he
had
and he said look back for the kids he
was like he said i've never been able to
give them anything and i've bought stuff
for you and then he was trying to show
me and he's like look go home and have
eat on me
go and do your eid make sure you tell
the kids that granddad got this view
for them for eid and he was like i know
they probably don't know me as a
granddad and i want them to but
please tell him it's for eid and it was
just so innocent and sweet because he
genuinely thought that you can have eid
at any time so i didn't say anything i
was like dad that's amazing thank you
they're gonna love it it's gonna be the
best eve they've ever had and
he was just so happy and he when i got
home he was saying like you know please
show me like all their eid stuff that
i've given them make videos and pictures
and stuff
and he's actually got a picture of me on
his wall in his in his living room now
like in my pub believe it or not in my
heart
yeah in my carbon with um pictures of my
kids with their hijabs on
he's actually got them in his living
room on his wall and he used to say like
the face spell was a bin bag and it's
horrible and you know these head scarfs
are like
taliban cloths you call them tell you
about their cheeks he said telling my
bed sheets
and stuff you know so it's true if my
dad can change
anyone anyone can change and it's really
it's really that simple
that's amazing man that's amazing well
i'll be honest i got a feeling he's
going to accept islam
you know i i i you can see the the the
the stuff that he's doing how he's
talking the stuff he's telling me
he's very close i would say take full
advantage of this and like i said before
this if you need we will travel there
like reading whatever it is you know we
will come there and stay with them
just take advantage of this because
inshallah because i can see like allah's
guidance
you know and and and he's taking that on
board as well inshallah
um and yeah subhanallah it's
it's it's absolutely uh amazing well
it's a really heart touching uh story
and yeah may allah bless you inshallah
uh for your time there's one thing i was
going to touch upon but i totally forgot
uh but yeah so what i would say is
sister may allah bless you inshallah
um i'm going to let me wrap you up i'm
going to send the video to you when i've
edited it you go through it and you tell
us what you think yeah
yeah so brothers and sisters inshallah i
hope you uh enjoyed that video inshallah
as you can see
we touched upon a lot of topics
inshallah and hope you guys have learned
and benefited from that as well
uh and um oh this is what i was going to
say i'm delighted it's good that we end
on this note
it's that and this goes with me because
i've always learned this as well
any time and because you're saying like
if my dad can change anyone can change
the reason here is because any time you
doubt yourself
be it that you're committing major sins
you're not praying salah
you're away from islam whatever it may
be or
parents whatever any time you doubt
yourself
like any time you say you know what i
can't do this remember who are lies
because you can't that's true you're
weak allah says we created mankind weak
but never ever forget who your lord is
so when you say this to me when you say
okay
if my dad can come to some you know what
it is how magnificent allah is and how
we do not fully fathom that
anytime you think this person will come
to islam allah's created heavens and the
earth
is it hard for allah to guide your
father or my father no it's not
so the thing is anytime we have a doubt
within ourselves
you know what my dad won't work my dad
won't accept islam
abcd you know what refer to allah
because allah
can change hearts and that's why i'll
end on inshallah promises hope you
enjoyed it share with your friends and
family inshallah and make dua
for the sisters family her husband her
kids
and her father inshallah and maybe in a
couple of months maybe she'll do a post
and say you know what my dad just
accepted islam and we wait to see that
day
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh